remember when executive orders were bad
but like really bad when it was
President Obama signing them at least
according to our current president but
now executive orders are good and
they're good because it's Trump and not
Obama and they're especially good and
justified if Donald Trump signs an
executive order to cancel something that
Barack Obama did and if you can do all
of that
Plus something terrible for the
environment then the move will be called
heroic by trumpets and that's exactly
what happened this week Donald Trump
very quietly signed an executive order
which revokes Obama era protections of
American oceans and coastlines and Great
Lakes consider that June is National
ocean month and during June Trump
revoked an order which will now
potentially allow drilling for oil in
90% of our offshore waters and it's just
about money this is terrible for the
environment it's self-destructive it's
irresponsible
and of course it happened very quietly
amid tons of other scandals and news
reports and barely made any headlines
and there are some legally interesting
questions here for example federal
versus states rights cities and states
can still pass laws to prevent offshore
drilling Trump federally has undone
protections against offshore drilling if
you're a supporter of states rights then
I imagine you would say just because
you're allowed to do it federally
doesn't mean that states have to allow
it if you take the federal supremacy
line then you could say well federal law
supersedes state law but of course
trumpets who say that are normally the
states rights type so that would expose
a pretty glaring double standard
although that wouldn't be hugely
surprising the most sober analysis of
that issue seems to be federal law could
trump state law except Trump can't make
law with an executive order and
therefore if there is a lawsuit the
verdict could be or should be that the
content of Trump's executive order
itself
isn't the problem but the problem is
that Trump is trying to make law
superseding state law via executive
order which I thought pat based on
separation of powers and checks and
balances
I thought presidents weren't supposed to
try to make law with an executive order
at least when President Obama was the
president yeah its Democratic presidents
Republican presidents can do that oh is
I forgot that's how it works yeah and
the problem is of course a hyper
partisan Congress right when you have a
hyper partisan Congress that can barely
agree about anything other than
basically policies that maintain the
status quo and confirm the power of
corporations and lobbyists Congress gets
nothing done
so then presidents use executive orders
Obama used one to try to protect the
oceans Trump is using one to try to
destroy the oceans and you get this
ping-pong of executive orders one
president does a the next president
cancels it and does B and we waste money
and time and political capital and the
cycle just continues and the problem is
that it's not just Obama bans it and
Trump allows it and then a Democrat bans
it again because while it is legal to
drill offshore in our oceans fossil fuel
companies will establish drilling
platforms if we get a Democratic
president next and they say I'm
canceling offshore drilling again good
luck getting those oil platforms shut
down once it gets going it is very
difficult to get it shut down after
these massive companies spend millions
and millions and millions of dollars
establishing these drilling locations so
this is a crisis and there's only one
way to fix it it's to vote them out we
have to keep track of all the damage
that we are going to have to undo at the
first opportunity will the opportunity
be in January when a Democratic House
and Senate gets sworn in after the
November election I don't know I wish I
were more confident will it be in
January of 2021 when a new president is
sworn in I don't know I wish I were more
confident I don't know when it's going
to be but we've got a lot of stuff
that we need to keep track of to try to
undo as quickly as possible and this is
pretty close to the top of that list
today's program is made possible in part
by better help.com slash Pakman this is
something I really believe in better
help gives you access to fully licensed
and experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer I have been talking for years
about the problem around people not
seeking help because of the stigma
around mental health services because of
the cost of mental health services and
all you have to do with better help is
go to better help calm slash Pakman
answer some basic questions you'll be
matched with a therapist that will be
right for you you can change therapists
if you don't think that it's a good fit
it's less expensive than seeing someone
in person you will still get the
professional help and it is unlimited
you can talk to a therapist every day
from home or wherever you are go to
better help calm slash Pakman it is so
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube better help calm
slash PA que ma n if you've been wanting
to talk to somebody but for whatever
reason haven't please go to better help
calm slash PA que ma N